hi my name is Tamra chambers and this is
episode two of Tamra's never seen and
today I'm going to be watching Jurassic
Park the first one because I've only
seen the third
Oh cameras never seen that was so good
you guys I finally get the alan joke
from the nostalgia critic review Alan
Alan Alan so the last movie that I
watched for the first time Return to Oz
was interesting to say the least
this movie was so good it was released
in 1993 and it still holds up incredibly
and there were no we but there were
Raptors so let's get started so right
off the bat this guy gets eaten by a
raptor so just you know what you're
getting yourself into no surprises
people are going to be eaten by
dinosaurs amazing they find the bug in
the trees happens and and it's like and
they're very excited about it and I'm
not I wasn't sure why at first then you
realize that it's a it's a mosquito and
the mosquito has eaten the blood of a
dinosaur so dinosaur DNA duh duh Tamra
my thing is like a mosquito probably
couldn't eat through a dinosaur skin
like like mosquitoes can eat through my
skin soft that's okay
that's a small that's a small thing
that's fine it's okay I'll let them have
it then you meet Ellie and Alan who are
an adorable couple who find dinosaurs
together and they're adorable at the end
but in the beginning they're not very
adorable they're kind of rough around
the edges takes a second for you to warm
up to them as a couple take Jeff
Goldblum hitting on Ellie for you to be
like aw Ellie and Alan though they're
good so all the archeologists are
looking at a buried Raptor on a computer
screen when this very snarky kid comes
up it's probably explained who the kid
is I didn't I didn't catch that it's
just a random kid on like this dig site
and he just goes that doesn't look very
scary that looks more like a six-foot
turkey to me also a 6-foot turkey would
be horrifying
also is that little boy jake gyllenhaal
then there's some exposition about Alan
not liking kids and Ellie wants kids and
are they a couple they are but they're
not married who are they doing they're
living in sin out of lo then John
Hammond shows up ruining everything in a
helicopter you're not supposed to love
him that much cuz he like kills people
in his amusement park but I love him so
passionate and just adorable and sweet
and it shows you how much an old white
man can get away with this is a side
note but I could not help but notice
inside of Ellie and Alan's trailer on
their fridge is like this amazing
newspaper article that says aliens ate
my face off fast-forward a bit you meet
Lois obviously I'm the bad guy we find
out he's working for Mr Hammond and he's
going to steal dinosaur embryos for the
bad guys who want to make dinosaurs but
they don't have the technology and you
see what they're going to transport it
in and it's literally like one of those
hideaways that people store like like
illegal drugs in like people in high
school that I knew had this for
marijuana
it's like a shaving cream thing but just
the top the bottom comes out he's like
dinosaur embryos no way that's what
they're hiding it in he's getting paid
like I don't know millions of dollars
for this but they're like here's a $6
weed hide away good luck
and Jeckle boom guys I guess I've never
seen him in much or anything but he's
ridiculous he is an outrageous person
and character what what what what are
you doing Jeff got witness but it's
what's happening I get it I get the hype
I'm on board now Karia I I get it okay
keep going so they're all in this
helicopter about to land on Jurassic
Park and you know Alan can't get his
dang seat belt to click because he's a
you know brilliant scientist and
archaeologist and he's like but they're
completely blindsided when they're
finally driving in on Jurassic Park and
they see the dinosaurs and they're just
like blown away which by the way I loved
that reveal it was so cool and so
exciting and they were so passionate
about it and like first Alan sees and
then she's just like really excited
about this leaf and she's like this
can't be real this was you know Exige
forever ago and then he turns her head
and and then you should see these
magnificent CGI
look it's CGI this is so exciting in
1993 well get used to it folks they do a
close-up of Ellie and Alan and they're
like tearing up and he's like my god
they do oh hold on my god they do live
in herds and they're passionate in
you're passionate like nothing can go
wrong
we're invincible then all the exposition
about the Raptors and the other
dinosaurs are all female so they can't
breed it's brilliant we changed their
chromosomes it's really not that
difficult if you think about it
exposition exposition it's never gonna
happen so it's obviously gonna happen
finds a way life
fines away they can you know no I cannot
I don't need you in here
I please don't hey go don't warn this
but I mean it's off it's not me I I will
destroy you forever go away so for some
reason all of them decide to go feed a
raptor and they're alarmed by the fact
that they're feeding the raptor a live
cow just kind of weird cuz obviously
Raptors aren't vegan like they're
definitely gonna eat meat hi I'm a
raptor I'm doing the whole vegan no
glucose thing I also do hot yoga then
everyone's like oh this is a terrible
idea people are going to die and the old
guys like well here are my grandchildren
then Alan sees the children and he's
like really weirded out that there are
kids there and he becomes this awkward
machine and he's super rude to them and
Ellie sees him being super rude to the
kids and is like making eyes at inlay
I'm ready for this I'm really ready for
you to suck at this I want kids now
fast-forward two seconds later and Alan
is acting way more like a kid than the
kids are
so they're on the car tour and they drop
a goat into one of the dinosaur exhibits
and we find out that the little girl is
a vegetarian you should not have come so
they're waiting for something to come
eat the goat and Jeff Goldblum is
flirting with Ellie and Alan could care
less and he sees a dinosaur in the
distance so he's like bye good luck with
this weirdo Alan finds his sick dinosaur
and they're trying to figure out what's
made it sick and they find these giant
poop piles and they're going to look
through it figure out what got the
dinosaur sick but the best part about
the scene is that Jeff Goldblum
Swagger's up to this pile of poop with
more swagger than I could ever muster
and he's walking towards again a pile of
poop poop so they're sitting in the car
and they realize that all of the
security for the park has been shut down
because mr. bad guy over there had to
steal his embryos and then it happened
it's the motherfucking t-rex get the
motherfucking team Rex it is it is the
motherfucking teeth Rex this scene is
amazing and it holds the fuck up it is
so good and it's scary and suspense
failed and the kids are like moving
around and she's got the light on
they're like who they can sense movement
and so Alan shoots off a flare and the
cheek Rex like goes after and then Jeff
Goldblum has to be the hero and he
shoots off another player even though
the dinosaurs all weird he already going
the other way and he's like I got it you
saved the children and so he's running
with the flare and it's like well he was
already doing that and so because of
that the t-rex then smells the lawyer
who ran away and he was in the bathroom
and and he eats the lawyer so lawyers
dead second person to die I'm pretty
sure from the dinosaurs so the lawyer
dies obviously that was obviously gonna
happen the whole time he's the worst
everyone hates him gonna die then the
bad guy Dennis dies obviously everyone
knew that was gonna happen - he's clumsy
and
and no one likes him so Alan saves
Timothy which thank goodness alive
because Timothy is Tim he's the best
character he just speaks to my soul
they're like in the top of the tree and
Alan's like let's climb down and
Timothy's like well it's impossible it
is I just ate the tree I would stay in
the tree I'm not going down there also
there's a dinosaur ISM I'm gonna stay in
the tree forever so this is where I live
now mean the tree are dating
then Ellie finds Jeff Goldblum who's
been like chopped up a bit not doing
great but he manages to recover in time
to say like this amazing line make sure
to tell John thanks for the lovely
weekend
explosions go up nothin I can't do an
impression of him obviously ask Rob
Walker he'll do it and anyone in the
world can do one except for me
apparently cuz I've never seen him in
anything then we find out that the
little girl is a hacker she's a
vegetarian she is a hacker and she's 11
that's more ambitious than I will ever
be just a side note I love the hold on
to your roots guy they're all trying to
devise a plan to get the kids back and
figure out how many raptors are out
there and it is driving Jeff Goldblum
crazy to sit there because his leg is
hurt and he's sitting there and he's
just like trying to smolder save
everyone like his legs are there he's
just hanging weird Ellie finally gets
the power back on and electrocutes Tim
he flies off it's amazing any lives of
course he's not gonna kill up to him but
it was an incredible scene okay
Alan's like you better come down from
there I'm gonna count to three and Tim's
like okay I'm so scared but I'm gonna
count to three and at least like ten out
of ten would recommend watching your den
and then after Ellie turns on the
electricity we find out that hold on to
your butt's guy has been eaten and the
Raptors have just been waiting for her
to do what she needs to do which is very
kind very considered of the Raptors I
don't remember how the kids and Alan get
separated but they do somehow
because Alan and Ellie then reunite and
they try to figure out how many Raptors
are loose and they decide to because
there are three but they can't open
doors so then they open doors the kids
lock one of the Raptors in a freezer
because the kids Rock then they're
trying to lock the second Raptor out of
the area that they're in but they can't
because the computers are down and they
need someone to have a oh wait the
little girl is a motherfucking half girl
so she hacks that shit like a fucking G
and she saves everyone's lives she saves
everyone and it is not realistic she's
like beep boop beep obliterate it then
the whole escape from the third Raptor
is very intense and then the
motherfuckin t-rex comes in and saves
them all and they escape then they all
make it onto this helicopter and it's
the end of the movie and mr. Hammond is
like reflecting and sad that it didn't
work out and Elly and Alan are like
smiling they're like maybe we can have
kids and Jeff Goldblum is like in the
corner and he's sad that he didn't have
sex with anyone because his legs were
hurt and this is the end it was so good
it was such a good movie I don't know
why I haven't watched it too well like
I'd heard so much about it but I felt
like I had seen it and I don't know why
I'd only seen the third but I've seen
the third like three or four times and I
loved the third I think that there is
really good I feel like I'm gonna love
every single movie that I watch for this
series so get ready for that get ready
for undying optimism the soundtrack is
incredible I loved the music it's so
good
one thing though I don't know if you
guys have noticed this or can seen
videos with other people pointing it out
but we finished the movie and I was
watching with my boyfriend and he
pointed out that about an hour and fifty
minutes in you see a Raptors whole body
in a doorway and you can clearly see
this tech person coming in with their
hand and like adjusting the Raptors body
just and it's there for a while like
it's like a couple it's a good chunk of
time that this person's hand is there
and it's so weird
it's so weird that they didn't notice it
or maybe they got the footage back and
they're like Fogg puck can't change it
now but let me know if there's more
instances like that and thank you so
much for watching that's the end
I'm Jeff Goldblum cut back to Jeff
Goldblum who's talking about how he's
always on the look for the future ex
mrs. Malcolm and then suddenly all of
America raises their hand like